[Musique]
aucun d'entre nous ne se connaît vraiment tous
merde mais d'une manière ou d'une autre nous étions tous au
même endroit au même moment quand
le point de Billie Fowler mon Dieu d'une manière ou d'une autre nous brillons
je vais bleu et noir ce que j'ose non non
tu n'es pas
le  des
choses de paille essayez
la réponse à ce qui vous arrive
est ici vous cinq êtes les Power Rangers
ai-je juste entendu dire guerre Power Rangers est-
ce une sorte de blague nous parlons à
un mur j'en attendais un peu
plus alors où  Étiez-vous la nuit dernière moi et
quatre enfants avons trouvé un vaisseau spatial enterré sur
le sol Je suis presque sûr que je suis un
super-héros qui a fait pipi dans ces rochers nos
Rangers étaient une légion de guerriers mais
devenez ces guerriers l'hologramme comme
un jeu vidéo
c'est un petit  vidéo d'hologramme de gaz tu es
né pour ça
elle est un pur mal
comment t'attendais-tu à ce cadre
plus que de temps nous parions que quelqu'un
ait jamais vu
[Musique]
ouais beaucoup d'or
est ton
destin c'est ton temps
ah
[Musique]